-You look sharp.
You look great.
-I look like
Herman Munster's friend.
[ Laughter ]
His best friend.
-His best friend you think
would -- Look at those guys.
[ Crowd cheers ]
-Boom!
I've stomped a lot of
lanternflies with these shoes.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-No, you would never hurt a --
That's what I always
said about you.
You would never hurt
a lanternfly.
-I am a gentle soul.
-You really are a gentle --
Hey, this is your 13th
appearance on our show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hope nothing falls on me.
-No, it's not unlucky.
Are you superstitious?
-A little bit.
I don't like to walk
under ladders.
-Me neither.
-I always knock on wood.
You don't --
-I do that too.
-Yeah, yeah?
-Yeah.
I've walked under a ladder,
though, before.
-And what happened?
-Nothing.
-Nothing?
-Absolutely nothing.
In fact --
-See, you got what you deserved.
Nothing.
-Nothing.
No, I was hosting
an MTV award show or something.
I was so nervous to go on.
And then they go,
"Oh, just go around this way
to get to the stage."
I go, "Okay."
And I went around
and it was a giant ladder.
So it looked like a, you know,
like just an archway.
And I walked in and
this guy was working,
and he goes,
"Oh, that's not good."
[ Laughter ]
You can't say that to me.
And I walked under the ladder,
but it turned out I had a great
show and nothing happened.
So I don't know
if that superstition
quite worked for me.
-Well, maybe it's silly.
Maybe I shouldn't
worry about it.
-I wouldn't worry about.
Oh, you know what else?
Have you ever opened
an umbrella indoors?
-Yeah, that one doesn't
bother me so much.
-Yeah, I don't believe
that either.
You know, I found out
the story behind that.
-What?
-Could you guess what the story
is behind the umbrella
superstition?
-Does it involve
somebody getting hurt?
-No.
-No?
-Does anyone
else know the story?
-Is it a Mary Poppins thing?
-I might be making this up.
But I think back in the day,
the man who invented --
or the woman
who invented the umbrella,
it was wooden,
wooden umbrellas.
And so if you brought
them indoors, you would --
If you opened them indoors,
you could dry them out.
But if you kept them closed,
the wood would rot,
and you'd have to buy
another umbrella.
So they told everyone
never open an umbrella indoors.
So you leave them closed
and the wood would rot
and you'd buy more umbrellas.
-So it was a way to keep --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
-He believes me.
She believes me.
-It's kind of like...
It's kind of like
what iPhone is now.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't update. Don't update or
else you got to buy another one.
Yeah, exactly.
Tomorrow's Halloween.
Are you excited for Halloween?
-I could care less.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It's a big holiday.
And you have --
-I mean, I'm an actor,
so I dress up like imaginary
or other people all the time.
-That's true.
This is not a holiday
for you, yeah.
It's not a treat
for you to dress up.
-It's like, "Give me my money."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. You've really become --
You've really become corporate
since I've had you on the show.
I've never seen you like this.
You have two young daughters.
As do I.
Are they into Halloween?
-Oh, yeah. They love it.
They love it.
I mean, my older daughter is 15,
so she's kind of aging out
of the trick or treating thing.
But we have an amazing house
in our neighborhood,
the Halloween house that people
come from miles around
to stare at this house.
And this guy who owns this house
I think has like 125
animated figurines on his porch.
And they're all
in different categories.
Like there's the zombie zone,
the clown zone,
spooky little kid zone.
His entire house is covered
with skeletons
climbing up the side of it,
and every year
he's got more stuff.
I just had one little guy, Sam,
who's got like a pumpkin
for a head, and he --
and if you step
on the little door pad,
he starts laughing
and waving a lollipop at you.
And I've seen
this terrify toddlers.
Make them start crying.
-Sam the lollipop
jack-o'-lantern?
-Yeah, it's from some movie
that I never saw,
but it's pretty scary.
But anyway, I prefer --
that's the more fun part.
-What are they dressing up as?
-Marion --
I think -- It keeps changing.
At last count it was --
She was going to try
and dress up as midnight,
which I thought was
rather lyrical, poetic.
-That is actually
a beautiful thing.
-Yeah.
She was going to have --
-Like a Taylor Swift thing,
maybe like with "Midnights"?
-I think. Yeah. I think that's
basically --
[ Crowd cheers ]
-My daughter --
-Taylor Swift.
-My daughter
is going as Taylor Swift too.
-Oh, really? Wow.
-Yeah.
Different album.
-Which one?
-1989.
-Oh.
[ Crowd cheers ]
That side of the room likes
"1989."
That side of the room...
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, it's nothing
but competitions
on "The Tonight Show" tonight.
-It's like a Rorschach test.
-It really is like
a Rorschach test.
Are you a Swiftie?
-Yeah.
[ Crowd cheers ]
You have to be.
You kind of have to.
Well, I know that
you're a musician.
-I am.
-You're a musician.
And actually, you're doing
a really cool thing.
Talk to me about this.
-Oh, dear.
-You have a band?
-Well, this fellow right here,
Jason Narducy,
is an amazing singer-songwriter,
jack of all trades.
And every once in a while
he says,
"Hey, Mike, let's do a record."
And we pick a record and we
play it from start to finish.
So this year was
the 40th anniversary
of R.E.M.'s record "Murmur."
-Whoo!
-And yeah, and we
played it in --
-Love "Murmur."
-Yeah, we played it in Chicago
in the summertime,
and it went pretty well.
And then Jason was like, "Why
don't we take this on tour?"
So he put it out there
to some clubs
and a lot of people
got back to us,
including in Athens,
Georgia, the 40 Watt Club,
which is actually where
R.E.M. started.
-That's right. Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And if you want to go
to that show, too bad
because it's already sold out.
But some of the other shows...
-You're giving out tickets or
something.
-Yeah, are still available.
-Some of the other tickets
are available?
-Yeah, yeah.
-But have you ever
met anyone from R.E.M.?
-I've been very blessed
to have met Michael Stipe.
Very, very sweet man.
[ Crowd cheers ]
And yeah.
-He's unbelievable.
-He's an unbelievably talented
person.
-He's actually an unbelievable
human being.
-Yeah. And Mike Mills actually
showed up at the Chicago show.
-What? Did you freak out?
-I freaked out. He walked in.
Basically,
we were in the green room
going through our set list.
-You're playing R.E.M.?
-Yeah.
-Ins and outs
of the R.E.M. show, yeah.
And right before we're about
to bound onto the stage,
Mike Mills walks
in the green room.
-You're kidding me.
-And everybody just kind of
gets, like, jittery,
And he's like, "Hey, I'm just --
I'm so excited to be here.
And I know you guys
must have worked so hard."
And he had a blast.
And he was really nice.
He hung out afterwards
and was very --
-Did he get up and play
or anything?
-He got up and sang
a little bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-He did?
-Yeah, yeah.
-See, that's what I'm
talking about.
That's a good --
-Now, I don't want to guarantee
that that's
going to happen ever again.
-But at least you can guarantee
at Athens, Georgia.
That's definitely
going to happen.
-Mike Mills will be there.
-We'll see. We'll see.
-"Murmur."
What have you got there?
What song you got off of murmur
that I would know?
It starts with
"Radio Free Europe."
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
♪ Calling out in transit ♪
-That's not gonna happen.
That's not gonna happen.
Which date do you want?
You can have one of these dates.
-I can go one of these dates?
-Yeah, yeah.
-I don't want to perform.
-You don't?
D.C., The Black Cat maybe.
-I'll be at The Black Cat.
-Yeah, yeah. Cool.
-Meorw.
[ Laughter ]
-I know that club.
Dude, this is fantastic
that you do this, though.
-Yeah.
-I love that --
I have to get to
these other projects
that you're doing also.
"Waiting for Godot."
I would be excited
to see you in this play.
-Yeah.
-Samuel Beckett.
This is a classic.
-It is.
-Have you ever done this before?
-No, I've never done
"Waiting for Godot."
But I saw it
when I was a little boy,
and I remember being mesmerized
by it,
and I kind of credit it with
one of the reasons I got into
theater was seeing that show
when I was a kid.
-Wow.
And now you're in it.
-And now I'm doing it.
-Yeah. That's wild.
And you play the young man
with the pumpkin head
and the lollipop?
-Yes, yes. I come to scare --
[ Laughter ]
-Sam?
-No.
-I'm playing Estragon,
which is unfortunately
very close to estrogen.
But it's not estrogen,
it's Estragon.
-Estragon. Estragon.
-Yeah, yeah.
And then my buddy Paul Sparks,
he's playing Vladimir
and he's -- we're old friends
and we've done a lot of work
together over the years.
-It's a brilliant play.
It's very funny and very --
makes you think.
Hey, by the way,
your directorial debut.
Congratulations.
You're now a film director.
-I did, yeah.
I directed a movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-You did a great job.
-Oh, thank you.
-"Eric LaRue."
-"Eric LaRue" is the name of
the film, and it's a --
How do we explain
what the film is about?
-Well, very briefly,
it's about the parents
of a young man
who commits a school shooting.
And at the start of the film,
he's in prison.
And it's really focusing
on the parents trying to deal
with the aftermath
of what he's done
and how -- the repercussions
it has on their lives
and their community.
-And Judy Greer?
-Judy Greer. Oh, my God.
-Knockout.
Knockout performance.
-You never seen --
-Knockout performance.
Everybody is fantastic
in this.
-Alexander Skarsgard.
-Skarsgard.
Yeah, it's great.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a scene from Michael
Shannon's directorial debut,
"Eric LaRue." Take a look.
-But the Lord.
Oh, he's the only one
who can judge.
And the only thing you should do
is leave yourself open
to healing and pray.
-Oh, stop it!
-Stop what?
-Stop talking to me like that!
I'm not in Sunday school!
I'm not a child!
-I don't think you understand.
-I understand more
than you think I do.
-I don't think you know
what you think.
-Do you think I'm stupid?
-Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Michael Shannon, everybody.
Congratulations.
Always great to see you.
-Thank you.
-"Waiting for Godot" premieres
this Saturday at
the Polonsky Shakespeare Center.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.